[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm link and i'm
rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are revisiting some
lyrics to songs that we did not
understand as kids but now that we are
men folk and fully understand
experienced all the things that there
are to understand in life well
you just slightly more than we
understood at the time uh wow
kind of blown away with what we were
singing and what we were wrapping and
what we were talking about back in the
day and i want to contrast it to how
things are these days so but
go ahead and tell me how did you
how did you get into this this was a
shepherd conversation yeah so uh last
week
on the same evening uh
my boys had uh shepherd had his middle
school dance and locke had his high
school prom
uh so boy it was just you know
lots of pictures being taken et cetera
et cetera and i think you're feeling the
dance fever i think that there is uh as
i think we said last time there will be
like a
your approach to prom slash
middle school dances because
next year you know lincoln will still be
he'll he'll have the prom
shepherd will have another middle school
dance so it'll still be fresh so we can
kind of give the dads giving advice to
uh
to kids episode during the season when
it's more pertinent
uh but this is how this came up because
i was just talking to shepard and i was
like uh so you gonna
you think you're gonna get out there and
dance just you know i don't know how
these things work anymore your
generation's so weird
yeah um and um and they've all been
cooped up in this pandemic they don't
know how to speak to each other they
forgot what the bottom half of faces
look like there's just a lot to overcome
and
um
he said i don't know you know i was like
you're gonna like you're gonna like ask
a girl do they answer anything i don't
know like there's lots of i don't knows
which is i guess a good place to be but
then he started asking me he was like
well tell me about your middle school
dances
and that led to talking about the time
that we did which we wrote about in the
book of mythicality where we basically
did a lip sync contest where you were
you were which is so appropriate now
that you're becoming a dj in your second
career
uh you lip synced as a dj
pantomime yeah as dj jazzy yeah yeah uh
anyway and then that led to as it turns
out i still have no clue how he does
what he does
now that led to
um a conversation about
us using every opportunity we got to
perform for our fellow students yeah
which led to the conversation about
taking over the fall festival in seventh
grade
eighth grade i think it was seventh
grade uh i mean it could have been sixth
grade and turning that opportunity of
being able to just having everyone
assembled at the fall festival which was
a way to talk about halloween without
saying halloween i guess in a small
christian conservative community
and how we took the song opp by naughty
by nature and made it instead of you
down with opp you down with halloween
which we had the privilege
of performing live on the tonight show
backed up by the roots can you believe
that happened
in the like stories will tell on the
porch i do think that it's a
it's a career
peak
yeah i mean hopefully there's nothing
it's not going to get any better than
that we may get back there we've had a
number of like uh
high points but that's definitely one of
them
and so that led to me saying
you know what it was the first rap we
ever wrote and performed like it wasn't
something i i'm still baffled by the
fact that it happened because it wasn't
like every year at the fall festival
some students would get up and perform
like at the talent i mean at the uh at
the dances yeah it was a con listening
contest you would enter i approached the
in the administration and asked
permission to do this yes just uh
something that you took the initiative
to do that was with with no
uh
you know there's
it the pattern had not been set you have
to set the pattern
um
but that's crazy that led to um
me saying have you ever heard opp
shepard
and of course he hadn't
and
while shepard is a connoisseur of music
and listens to a lot of old school stuff
he doesn't listen to much old school
hip-hop
so yeah
i turned on opp and began to play it and
i of course i know what it's about i
know what opp stands for
uh because that's what the song is
telling you about the whole time well it
was other people's property but as
you'll get into the lyrics it's more
specific than that very
very so you played the song for shepard
and he was just like
like putting his hand on his forehead
and like just shaking his head like was
he listening to the lyrics or was he was
he reacting to the production
or like just the style
so we listened to the first verse and he
was taking in a lot right and then i
said
shepherd
are you really listening to the lyrics
uh-huh
and he said kind of i said okay well
we're starting over
so i rewound it well it doesn't rewind
it doesn't happen anymore i'm old i just
started the song again
and at that point it was when he was
processing exactly what was being said
which
now there's we don't have there's no
embarrassment in our family about
talking about these things so it wasn't
like oh dad i can't believe you're doing
this you're embarrassing me he was just
like i can't believe that this was a
thing that was happening culturally i
guess
but it's still it's still happening as
we might demonstrate later but it was a
huge song i mean it was everywhere it
was i mean it was definitely a crossover
hit it was like
middle school dances absolutely playing
the song
and like i said i knew what it was about
but i had just forgotten the explicit
nature so i'm going to read the lyrics
to opp and this came out august 24th
1991.
[Music]
so we were
13. uh and for effect just to clarify i
will not be trying to deliver these
rhythmically or in any relation to the
song not for legal purposes but because
it is more entertaining to read them as
if you are reading a poem
um
arm me with harmony
dave drop a load on him
those are some introductory things that
were said yeah and
i guess dade was dave was the dj and he
was or the and he was dropping the beat
yeah
opp how can i explain it
i'll take it frame by frame it
to have y'all
jumping shot with saying i don't know
you that's what the
only one rule you can't start doing the
lyrics
and singing the song that's mine i'm not
going to sing it
let me go through this okay okay you go
through yours okay
to have you all all jumping shouting
saying it
o is for other p is for people scratch
your temple
yeah think about it think about it
the last p well that's not that simple
huh
it's sort of like oh well another way to
call a cat a kitten
[Music]
yeah it's five little letters that are
missing here
you get it on occasion if the other
party isn't gaming
it seems i gotta start the explaining
bust it
yep you ever had a girl and met her on a
nice hello hello you get her name and
number then left feeling real mellow
you get home way today she's what you
want to know about then you call up and
it's her girlfriend's or her cousin's
house oh
it's not a front an f to the r to the o
to the n to the t yep that is how you
spell it it's just her boyfriend's at
her house oh that's why she's scary
ah it's opp time other people's but you
get it there's no room for relationships
there's just room to hit it
how many brothers out there
know just what i'm getting at
you think it's wrong because i was
spitting and co-hitting that co-hitting
that that's that's a good lyric
well if you do that's opp and you're not
down with it but if you don't here's
your membership
oh you down with opp yeah you know me
you down with opp yeah you know me you
down with opp i don't feel comfortable
saying yeah you know me actually who's
down with opp
all the homies every last homie every
last homie
you down with opp
yeah you know me you're down with opp
yeah you know me you're done with okay
you know me who's down with opp
all the homies
well and now we got to flip the script
for the ladies opp means something
gifted
the first two letters the same but the
last is something different you see how
he got to different probably tried
different the first time now don't be
no commentary on the on the lyrical
choices
i don't want to criticize this is like
this is a classic it's a hit treach has
a lot of respect better than i could
have done
as a as a lyricist as is evidenced by
get down with halloween which we will
not be reading
uh it's the longest loveliest lean
i call it the leanest
he's got to get to that rhyme it's
another five-letter word rhyming with
cleanest or meanest
[Laughter]
so he's talking about penis
the past tense of being penised
oh my gosh i won't get into that
really
i'll do it uh sort of properly i'll say
the last p
stands for property now lady here comes
a kiss
blow a kiss back to me now tell me
exactly have you ever known a brother
who had another like a girl or wife
and you just had to stop a toast because
he looked just that nice
you now first of all some of these lyric
sites this is genius.com sometimes i get
it wrong sometimes they get it wrong so
don't hold that again
it sounds rightish to me
um you looked at him he looked at you
and you knew right away he had someone
but he was going to be yours anyway
you couldn't be seen with him at all and
still you didn't care cause in a room
behind a door no one but y'all are there
when y'all are finished y'all can leave
and only y'all would know
and y'all could throw that skeleton bone
right in the closet door
go
now don't be shy because if you're down
i want your hands up high say opp
like to say with pride now when you do
it do it well and make sure it counts
you're down with a discount
look can i just interject and say you
have never sounded more
white dad yeah right and you do right
now that's well i'm a white dad
i'm just being myself
and the same thing happens again the
whitest and deadest uh this time is
every
last lady and all the ladies it won't
let you go through that it goes both
ways it takes two to tango and let me
just run it actually takes at least
three but only two are tango this is a
long song let me just rush through the
third verse i don't even remember the
third scab tried to opp me i had a girl
and she knew that matter of fact her and
my girl was partners that had a fallout
disagreement yes an argument she tried
to do me so we did it in my apartment
bust it
that wasn't the thing it must have been
the way she hit the ceiling whoa
because after that she kept on coming
back and catching feelings
i said let's go my girl is coming so you
gotta leave she said oh no i love you
treech tretch tretch yeah he spelled it
with the ea
i said
now child please
you guys to leave come grab your coat
right now you gotta go i said now look
you chose the stairs or choose the stair
window oh my gosh
that was a fling a little thing you
shouldn't have brought your heart
because you know i was opp hell from the
very start come on come on now let me
tell you that it's all what it's all
about when you get down you can't go
running off at the mouth that's rule
number one in this opp establishment you
keep your mouth shut and it won't get
back to her or him exciting isn't it a
special kind of business many of you
will catch the same sort of opp messing
with him or her for sure i'm going to
admit it when opp comes damn skippy i'm
with it
the thing that strikes me i let my 13
year old be educated by that we never
received this level of education we
never thought about the lyrics in this
way i mean there were certain songs at
the time
that i was thinking about the lyrics if
they were like a story if it was a story
song or if it was like something really
just blatant like a like young mc
rapping about bust a move you got this
girl at the at the wedding and you're
you're feeling like you want to be it
was the only way i could follow it
this is over you this isn't hard to
follow but like
but
rhythmically it was so catchy
and it was it was a little harder to
follow because he was and is a really
good emcee so i'm gonna put it on that
not just on us
but i mean and this was i mean it was it
was such a huge song but we were
listening to other lyrics and processing
them but i never thought
this is something that i disagree with
you know cheating on like
glamorizing glorifying cheating on your
partner
as something that
you can that is set up as like a
cultural norm
like hey if everybody's playing by these
same rules
there's nothing wrong here if nobody
finds out you know it's like
i
i would have felt i mean we wouldn't
have agreed with that but we were also
middle schoolers but we also would have
thought about it
anyone thinks about music in that way
well parents don't
parents are like oh you can't listen to
this
because you will adopt the philosophy of
the person rapping who may or may not be
playing a character by the way do you
know what i'm saying like
yeah definitely
but
it was that was never a danger
i never thought about having sexual
license
as a middle schooler now if i was in
college listening to this it might give
my give me some umph
of course not in not not when we were in
college the way we were in college we
would
we would listen this this stuff and
i will note
you know i'm talking about college but
to go back to this exact era like taking
the nwa tapes that your brother would
secretly buy
and sometimes they would be so raunchy
that he would find a way to edit the
tapes himself like since they're the
tapes a couple of songs he had to censor
the entire song off the table they just
don't bite it was one of them
yeah so and we were listening to that
stuff too that was like it was like
musical pornography oh it was so
explicit and very misogynistic
it was very problematic but yeah we
heard it you're right but for some
reason we drew the line at two live crew
i don't know what my brother did
i don't think your brother liked the
music it wasn't as good it wasn't it
wasn't the miami sound is not something
that we really it wasn't as good as nw
it is kind of
um
and that was at the exact same time so
those lyrics were like blatantly
pornographic
i mean they were like
there were sound effects of of
sex acts
and skits
and so all of this stuff was happening
so this was
this was coded
it wasn't that code this is why it could
be popular but it wasn't like on radio
there were no curse words and so it
played on the radio yeah there was not
there was not profanity wasn't playing
on the radio well one of the things that
yeah i i think that there's a there's
it's interesting because
you would listen to
wrestling reach number six on the hot
100. you would listen to rap a pop hit
to learn lyrics
i never did that that was not i i i
would never like i'm going to listen to
this again so i can learn the lyrics i
might learn them by osmosis you know
just listening over time
but
i just i didn't ever
it didn't
i didn't start processing lyrics to
songs
until i was an adult and i still often
don't process lyrics to songs unless
it's like oh this is really this is
something meaningful here and i'm going
to like really listen to it
so i'd say 95 of the music that i
listened to as a kid was just washing
over me and now
yeah and i couldn't have told you what
it was about
yeah and i i think that's relatively all
it takes is a little coding that's what
he did just a little bit it's the
longest lean some call it the leanest is
another five letter word rhyming with
cleanest and meanest that's not a lot of
coding no not really but we we didn't
think about it you tell me he's talking
about penis
what
so you're saying that you didn't know he
was talking about penis when he said if
i knew he was talking about penis i
didn't like then i didn't i didn't then
zoom out to try to interpret the whole
song it was like in that line he said
something about wieners ah it just
sounds good i own the i had this tape
i listen to every song on this tape so i
i'ma skip to another i'm gonna go to
1995.
but first hey we want we got to talk
about mythicon on this freaking podcast
tickets are available to everyone not
just mythical society members so listen
mythicon
the
most mythical event in the history of
mythicality the most mythicality put
into one weekend in austin this is this
is a convention in real life do we need
to say that uh yeah it's mythicon it's
it's it's a convention mythical beasts
austin texas descending upon
a
like
western town
uh outside of austin texas that we're
we're basically going to just take over
this this town for a couple of days
and it's it's like a mythical circus
coming through a western town it has
this like sideshow kind of like uh
i was gonna it's not i was gonna say ren
faire but no it's not red fair but in
the way that like we're going all in
like you're entering another world in
that way
it is october 28th
through the 30th
get your tickets now before they are
gone it's gonna be worth it this is this
is gonna be history making it's gonna be
something that
we can build on
you know and say hey this is an amazing
experience for the select group of
people it's very uh it's limited
capacity you know with this
venue that we've got
centrally located that's why we picked
austin and and also because the venue is
like
thematically awesome it that limited the
number of tickets we could sell to
create an experience for the people who
are able to get a ticket yeah so
i'm concerned it's going to sell out
quickly
uh we'll see how it goes but don't take
that chance this is this is this is
where you want to be with us
in austin for that weekend so it's
mythicontickets.com
uh to get those tickets there's
different packages that you can get as
well and i will say that you know we've
been talking about this and planning
this for multiple years
honestly since we stopped touring yeah
um and just with our schedules and the
way that things are sort of structured
with all the stuff that we have to do
the thinking was hey instead of
traveling around
let's have everyone come to one place
right yep and so
this is what we're putting this is what
we're investing in this is what we're
uh we're trying to put the most
mythicality all together in person in a
way that we've never done before so we
really hope to see you for the most
mythical experience possible mythicon
2022.
so mythicaltickets.com i'm going to go
to 1995. like i said i got to talk about
how alanis morissette came on the scene
you know
she brought it
you ought to know
um it's a great documentary
uh i can't remember what it's called now
but it's uh it's on uh hbo
all about her rise to fame it's really
good especially the first two thirds
um
but
you ought to know
uh
i mean
she's upset she's she's her her man who
some people say is dave coulier but she
did she's not coming out
and saying that she says it's like an
amalgamation of people i think in the
documentary she she skirts the issue
she's not it's not the type of thing
that like
she seemed to say it was kind of a
ridiculous assumption but she didn't and
that she didn't address it which uncle
is that from full house
no uh
he's the one with the uh i know he's the
one
i want you to know i'm happy for you
it's i mean
at her age like she was so young like
writing these lyrics uh i wish nothing
but the best for you both an older
version of me is she perverted like me
this is the very beginning of the song
would she go down on you in a theater
what does that mean right there one two
three four five lines into the song that
means she goes to pick up your popcorn
if you drop it
she's making thinking about the theater
staff does she speak eloquently in which
she have your baby i'm sure she'd make a
really excellent mother
um
yeah which
would she go down on you in a theater i
mean the second verse really i i never
thought about that i didn't know what
that meant going down in a theater yeah
i don't think i knew at the time well
you're saying 95.95 oh yeah
i guess we knew by that point yeah
but you didn't but we had somebody had
to tell us you don't want to think it
was on the radio though it's like
there's no way that's what she means if
this is on the radio
the somebody from dunn had to tell us
second verse hits hard too
you seem very well
things look peaceful i'm not quite as
well yeah we kind of picked up on that i
thought you should know did you forget
about me mr duplicity i hate to bug you
in the middle of dinner so you realize
this entire exchange is a confrontation
where he's out on a date with her
saying these things
she's there
yeah does she go down on you in the
theater
does she speak eloquently maybe later is
she gonna have oh i'm sure she'd make an
excellent mother like going to say
titanic later pretty great
uh
it was a slap in the face how quickly i
was replaced and are you thinking of me
when you [ __ ] her i'll link so that got
that was bleeped on on the on the radio
yeah but i mean
that was that was quite an entrance to
the scene
[Music]
so i
it was hard to ignore i think the down
on unit theater yeah we had to know what
that meant at the time and boy that was
it was just
it was intriguing i think about that
thing well by 95 it happened the two of
us got this chick who's like bringing it
uh the two of us are uh
well established in a christian band
uh
making our own music at the time
uh listening to secular music
exclusively
secular
and
nuclear bombs
uh
the um
i don't remember thinking that like i
didn't buy an atlantis more set tape or
cd like i but i was like oh that's
that's that's catchy it's a catchy song
but she felt
dangerous a little bit dangerous even
though we listened to secular music
it felt like
we would divide things into uh sort of
you know godly and worldly right and she
was definitely on the worldly side and
she was like kind of reveling in it she
was a little bit she was a little scary
a little intimidating
yeah at the time
there was that's
unabashed subversion
which was i mean but it was she was
really just talking about something that
was true to her experience that like
tapped into what
you know
just the rage of like being
being dumped
but i think what i'm saying is that we
had a tendency to
lose because
with our world view you just put things
in two categories like this is good and
this is bad and worldly right and when
you do that when you have a filter that
it kind of just
shifts everything into the worldly box
all the nuance and all the wisdom and
all the interesting insights that you
can get from that yeah art is lost and
so you're just like this is not i mean
again we weren't prudes and so we didn't
we listened to it but we secretly judged
it as we were listening to it and we
never thought that like this is like
this isn't just a catchy song but
you know this is about a woman
scorned you know what i'm saying and
like eloquently bringing i mean it's
still very 90s lyrics in a lot of ways
but
uh
you know you just lose all the nuance of
of everything yeah
because i remember thinking
i was so into tribe called quest
that's why i'm actually wearing a shirt
today um
because i'm actually wearing a shirt
today instead of being that says it
instead of being shirtless like i was
planning on
um
yeah in 1991
when i really got into them it was there
was this i was relieved that they rarely
cursed and it was like pretty tame it
was a choice that they made
and so like i didn't feel
they were like very cool
like one of the one of the best is
classic hip-hop album but it was like i
had pr i permission to listen to it
without like feeling like i had to sneak
around or like i was doing something
wrong right it was it was the first
tape that i had that was like it was it
felt
safe to me but still very cool yeah for
that reason what what you what you got
next because i got some stuff i i mean i
had to hit the
atlantis theater line
but
we may have some overlap here because
there's some stuff in those like middle
school early high school days
that is just ridiculous on the radio
uh i'm going to talk about garth brooks
oh you are
that summer
[Laughter]
okay you're gonna go in this direction
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah i love this
this is such a good song now this is a
story song garth brooks um it's funny
because
well i think one reason is because he
doesn't put his music on spotify
uh
but like i also
i was so into garth brooks in middle
school yeah and a little bit a little
bit in high school
but it was justified i s but i didn't i
didn't remain a garth brooks fan i
didn't listen to garth brooks in college
really i didn't listen to garth brooks
in the like i didn't do it in my 20s 30s
you know i go back and listen to it and
i'm like it's interesting how
this music broke through in such a big
way
and it connected with me in such a
significant way but i like i listen to
it now and i'm like
it wasn't as good as i remember i don't
know what i don't know what's going on
spotify you listen to an apple or
something
are you even getting it
you going to walmart
where it's exclusively sold
i know
there's so there's a way that you can
listen to it i can't remember how i have
and it didn't maybe amazon it didn't tap
into it for you
no but this song surprising uh
this song that summer
i i what i would do is i would like sit
in the back seat of the car when my
family was driving and
going someplace and we would put on
garth brooks and i would sing it and
they would like
rhett sing that song sing sing the river
know what dream is like i mean for those
first two albums i don't think he missed
every song was just great but i'm pretty
sure my parents never got me to sing
this song in their presence
i went to work for her that summer
a teenage kid so far from home
she was a lonely widow woman hell bent
to make it her on her own
we were a thousand miles from nowhere
wheat fields as far as i could see
both needing something from each other
not knowing yet what that might be
well i think one party might have known
what that might be
till she came to me one evening oh hot
cup of coffee and a smile oh coffee in
the evening
what's the late night in a dress that i
was certain she hadn't worn in quite a
while
there was a difference in her laughter
there was a softness in her eyes yeah
and on the air there was a hunger even a
boy could recognize
a boy okay so a boy here he said he's a
teenager a teenage kid and she's a
lonely widow woman so i mean in my mind
he's again let's say can we say he's 18.
we really can't um
i mean let's just say that for
for the benefit of
everyone he's 18.
she's 46. yeah she is
but she actually she maybe i don't well
no she's a farm woman it talks we give
we get some details about her physically
in a second
okay uh but she's been in the sun so
it's kind of hard to tell well let's get
to it
but we're assuming they're both in their
sexual prime at this point which is
a sexual prime for a woman is what early
30s okay so i think she's beyond that
well let's see
uh but she's still feeling the thunder
uh because
oh yeah she had a need to feel the
thunder this is the chorus
to chase the lightning from the sky to
watch a storm with all its wonder raging
in her lover's eyes wow she had to ride
yes the heat of passion like a comet
burning bright russian headlong in the
wind out where only dreams have been
burning both ends of the night that is a
good chorus burning both ends of the
night i mean that is i mean burning both
ends of the night that means you're st
you're staying up until the morning yeah
i mean that means you're making love
both ends of the night
what this is about making love
maybe
second verse that summer wind was all
around me
oh okay
so they're
outside
nothing between us but the night
at yep and when i told her that i'd
never
it's other naked
she softly whispered that's all right
and then i watched her hands of leather
okay she's 80.
turn to velvet in a touch
well hands of leather well okay okay you
know 80 is like age spots
that's like i have some
no
h
okay again i'm placing this woman she
she she she's a she's a farmer woman
worked the land
she's been in the sun well she may have
she worked the land necessarily but
she's she's working for herself now
she's a widowed woman that lives out
planes
you know
at this time he's singing this song in
the 90s it probably of course it didn't
happen to him but if it happened to him
then it would have happened in like the
80s 70s sunscreen not really a thing i
think you can have leathery skin at 40.
honestly okay let's say but lonely widow
woman well he'd push him in late 40s no
i think i know you know he got
he got some sort of like
i don't know a young man's disease
what's that
benjamin button
no no i mean he died young
you know car accident tractor accident i
don't know oh oh the husband yeah
she's 46 let's say she's 43.
i think you got to push upper 40s man
hands of leather he's really selling it
here fine
then i watch her hands of leather turn
the velvet in a touch
there's never been another summer when i
have ever learned so much so he just
leaves the verse there she had a need to
feel the thunder he goes back into the
course chase the lightning from the
skies
watch the storm and also want a raging
in her lover's eyes well she taught him
things
rushing what headlong head russian
headlong you know where the head is
long
in the wind
now where only dreams have been he's
fantasized someone's fantasized it might
be her about this now this is a let me
let me just say okay i'm gonna be a
little vulnerable here and i appreciate
not being immediately judged for it uh
but i'm sure i will be but i just got to
say that for most um
uh
when we were in high school
most boys
without exception
had a fantasy
to get with a teacher
okay i'm just going to say it was highly
inappropriate
i'm not saying you don't even have to
say most boys but yeah it was it was a
trope it was a common it was common i am
i am staking my claim on most boys had a
fantasy about being with a teacher if
there was what they would consider a hot
teacher at the at the school okay seemed
like a great idea to me
there you go we're two boys our sample
size is two
and we both thought it would be awesome
yeah
um and so
and i'm not commenting on the morality
of any of that i'm just saying that this
is something that this is a fantasy that
lives in the minds
and the loins
of many teenage boys
and i think that garth understood that
in a powerful way
and so i think that's why this song was
so popular but nobody wanted to talk
about it nobody wanted to
uh
admit that's why it was popular give me
the third verse because i want to i want
to see if we can remember how much we
processed
okay but but but you can't leave out the
third verse
i often think about that summer okay so
now he's looking back on how does he
feel about it now the sweat the
moonlight and the lace okay
and i've rarely held another when i
haven't seen her face oh wow her wrinkly
leathery face
and every time i pass a wheat field
and watch it dancing with the wind
although i know it isn't real i just
can't help but feel her hungry arms
again wow so there's a bit of
it's
it defined
sexual
sexuality for him in a lot of ways you
know it's like this kind of he's been
saddled with it
it's been saddled with that experience
and but he's taking the lessons that she
taught him into every subsequent
relationship
do you know what i'm saying yeah but
he's like still seeing she was he's like
obsessed she was his sensei she's dead
now you know she aged she aged out well
that's hard living out there the wind
right it's like blow you're right into
the grave
was it only older women from there on
out i don't know older women make
beautiful lovers that is another song
yeah not gonna read those lyrics
do you remember
like just really really jiving with
these lyrics
i don't okay i'm gonna be
another step in vulnerability oh here we
go i'm gonna say that
uh i am
90 sure
be try to try to try to tell me like you
would if you were tretch you know you
got to veil it a little bit no no well
i'm no i'm speaking mathematically
because i am 90 sure that 30 percent of
the time that i listened to this song i
had an erection oh
so so i sent sure that 39 sure that 30
of the time so it's almost positive that
a third of the time that i listened to
the song that i got an erection well
you're really saying you could like it's
almost like you're saying 23 of the time
with 100 certainty if i don't
you had an erection so that's still
that's still almost a quarter of the
time it means i probably had an erection
yeah
so yes so you're in the back seat of the
car with your parents i said that they
didn't they knew what was up they didn't
ask me to sing this one yeah but just it
comes on the radio oh yeah no i'm
talking about alone in my room
passionately
singing this
and then just
trying not to masturbate but you to so
i want to go
i
i haven't
i have something that's almost directly
related but role reversal so i want to
go there next but before i do i just
want to acknowledge that like
nowadays the stuff that you can get on
like i was
i was like i'm going to pick a different
spotify
playlist
uh besides wrapped caviar to listen to
while i'm coming down this mountain i
was like i'm gonna put on feeling myself
this is another
uh
playlist the hip-hop playlist that's a
whole mood i was like i need a mood
going down this mountain well it turns
out it's basically all female rappers
you've got like
um
uh
megan v stallion
nicki minaj doji cat
um erica banks coy larae
but okay i mean
so i mean
especially by the time [ __ ] comes
along and i mean it's like
yeah
you [ __ ] with some wet ass
like this this is explicit again and
again and again
like just referring to
you know it's it's it's a v it's a it's
a female empowerment song it's like hey
i like sex i have i have
sex organs i have desires
and i can be in charge and i can say how
i want this done and i can say what i
bring to the table and i cannot
apologize for anything
and so there's this whole movement
that you know you've got
i'm a
i'm just trying to [ __ ] this
inward out
[ __ ] him out gargle on his kids then
spit him in his mouth oh my goodness i
told him slurp me up like spaghetti
he thought he was a freak till he met me
and now i'm finished show him what it's
about
gargle on his kids yeah so this is baby
tate [ __ ] him out again
you know there's a
genus correct me if i'm wrong here
jenna's the expert here but this is
this is like hey
as a female they're saying
i can
i can i can engage in lyrical sexuality
as well this is not something that
should be reserved for the men
back in the 80s and 90s this is
something that hey i i it's my body it's
my desires it's my world
slurp up my spaghetti oh right you know
and it's just so out there i mean
first of all what is radio anymore but
like
this is just out there i mean i give a
family account to
and then like there's age restrictions
for like lando but like i mean
lincoln 17. lilly's off of college i
mean i would implement his own age
restrictions i don't think you actually
have you don't have to do it um
but you know it's
it's
where is this going to go from here i
don't know it seems like it's we fully
arrived at like
i'm putting my sexuality out there and
i'm speaking about it in explicit terms
and it's it's mainstream the way we
talked about
nwa like there was a lot of misogynist
lots of lots of problems with that
objectification
you know the list goes on and on but you
know for something that can be to some
people could be equally as
uh offensive because of the words and
concepts that are used but then it's
like
yeah when i heard about wap i was like
why is this being celebrated this is
like
i i feel embarrassed you know this is
this is very explicit
and so
what i said is how i began to understand
it so you're saying that it's such a
progression if you go back to uh garth
brooks and this the 46 year old wheat
farmer's wife yeah yeah yeah what she
was really saying when she was saying
come ride the she wants to ride the
thunder and she was like come
slurp my spaghetti is which
yeah and now
now this you know stir my cowboy chili
this me
this many years later
um
it's just you can just say it
just say it directly but in 1997 if you
listen to
uh
the group next seeing too close
baby when we're grinding that's right i
get so excited
oh how i like it
i tried but i can't fight it
oh you're dancing real close
plus it's real real slow
now you know what you're doing don't you
you're making it hard for me
i think i know what it means
and then
and then the girl starts singing and
she's like
step back you're dancing kind of close i
feel a little poke coming through
on you and this is pre-facebook
right
that was just a weird song back in 1997
it's like
on the radio
yeah talking about the
just the dancing dynamic of
i'm experiencing an erection uh-huh yep
something you have to worry about when
you're just
in your room alone with garth brooks
[Laughter]
i mean that was just a weird so i i
i mean you hear this song on the radio
and it's just like this is just
yeah this this does happen
this this is something to be aware of
this is educational but this is a this
is a bit too blatant like there's not
you know it's easy
you want to criticize them it's not that
artistic
but again
i don't i don't want to start applying
that to megan the stallion
well you mentioned uh i'd like to i'd
like to meet her with a clean conscience
and say i've never said anything
negative about you like i think you're a
great person let's be friends you
mentioned
[ __ ]
you know someone else was talking about
wetness
um back in the day
emcee hammer
oh you're gonna go you're gonna do this
yeah so i'm going back to m.c hammer
because what mc hammer uh represents
is how on this on the same album in fact
almost
back to back but actually there's a song
in between you're talking about the the
when he blew up we're talking uh you
can't touch this days that album
actually i don't think that these two i
think these two might be on please
hammer don't hurt them oh
which is the second album and then the
third blue that blew up was uh no no no
it's on police hammer don't hurt him
that's what i said yeah that's the one
with you can't touch this oh i thought
the police amber don't hurt him was oh
okay okay so it was the first one no
it's his second album that's when he
really blew so you can't touch this was
on police hammer don't hurt him yep
that's what i've been trying to say all
right 1990
so it's his third studio album again as
uh
white kids in bowie street north
carolina at the time
um
you can't touch this was just like
i it was just something you know it just
was like
spoon feeding us with yeah when you're
12 years old
it's that's amazing man so on this album
there's two songs and i'm going to read
the lyrics to to kind of
this was confusing for me at the time
because we had soft and wet
yes and then we had
pray we gotta pray just to make it today
almost back to back
uh
i'm gonna i'll run through this pretty
quickly uh soft and wet
yeah soft and wet that's how we like
them
soft and wet yo baby come here yo baby
tell me what's your name they call me
hammer and i'm rose from the game i see
your face it stands out from the crowd
move a little bit closer let me be your
style
i'm crazy baby i'm crazy about your love
let me tell you about myself now i'm a
little bit different than the average
joe i like my girls and then i like a
little bit more excuse me girl i don't
mean no disrespect but tell me girl are
you soft and wet
yeah crazy baby i'm crazy about your
love i'm gonna tell you
i know how i like them
i like them soft and wet
i like them soft and wet check it out
you say you want me well i want you to
you say you need me girl then i need you
you say you love me well i love you too
but there's a few things that we got to
do i'm crazy baby i'm crazy about your
love how we like them homeboys
soft and wet yeah
i told you we like them soft and wet let
me explain myself myself again
soft and wet
how we like him in the front
so
my homeboys in the back how you like
them oh they're talking about not the
front and back of of the uh partner
talking the front and back
you got you with that all you need to
say for this part soft and wet
pump it up pop it up pop it up
soft and wet soft i don't know this song
because i would always fast forward on
the tape i wouldn't listen to this song
it wasn't a good song as a 12 year old i
would not do it soft is the feeling of
your baby smooth skin
great so we're not talking leathery
hands is he about to describe the wet
food
what is the feeling that says let the
hammer in
okay
you know what the hammer is
soft and sexy he's it's his uh wrap this
is his rap name you got it that way what
is what happens when we both start to
play
good she is i should know hype the
feeling with my ninja starts to grow
so he he just admitted to it being
normally hidden
uh well he's a grower not a shower it's
okay i think he's saying he's
uncircumcised it's hooded oh
wow link that is some insight you're
right yeah empty hammer is not
circumcised i've never seen it
but yeah it seems that he's uncertain
and we met him
from a distance at a party but i
couldn't tell from that distance he lost
he's also clothed
he made an announcement from the dj
booth
if anybody finds hammer's phone
bring it to me yeah i'm hammer
okay
uh
yeah and then pray was right after that
so it's like all right and then when you
get
i don't know
uh hard and dry we can go to church okay
so this is just called pray
pray was actually a single which is
weird that's word we pray pray pray are
you trying to cleanse
us by reading these lyrics i don't want
to hear them pray they did come out what
this song sucked
just we got to pray just to make it to
the day i said we pray pray pray oh yeah
we pray pray we got to pray just to make
it today i listened to this one because
i felt like
it was christian um
yeah it's pretty simple message here
but i think that
the thing i didn't understand is that in
my particular world view at the time
these
uh the softness and the wetness
uh which i was obviously very into the
idea of
um
that wasn't something that god wanted
for me yet and i don't believe that
hammer was talking about his wife
you know what i'm saying right so like
we can talk about softness and wetness
if you're talking about your wife
song of solomon right okay yeah it's in
the bible
uh but you should probably shouldn't
make a song about it you know keep it in
the bedroom
but i was just like man he's like
talking about this thing but then he's i
mean if you can put it in the bible you
can make a song about it right but then
he's then he's praying and he's in his
there's he's not apologizing for it i
didn't i didn't understand and now it's
like i can understand it now you know
i'm a i'm a spiritual being i'm a sexual
being
and you know i i'm not going to speak
into the culture
that hammer came from
beyond the fact that okay there's
there's a church there's a church
element and there's a sexual element i
mean it's not just so i'm not saying
anything really about black culture or
growing up in oakland or wherever he was
from
i it's i think it's true to it's it's a
human truth you know we're sexual beings
we're spiritual beings and also wetness
is an important part of the process i
mean let's just be honest
right i mean that's an indication that
we're all on the same page
i mean yeah obviously the main that's
the main indication is verbal consent
let me be clear about that but but i'm
saying that yeah and also being of an
age of consent
right and as we established he was 18.
garth was 18 when he made love with that
46 year old wheat farmer well okay i i i
need to take us to another place that's
a little don't get in here don't don't
get it twisted well i'm going to twist
it oh gosh okay because first of all i
want to talk about um knocking the boots
which is
you know uh
an h-town song from from the 90s
uh
give me some good love some body rock
and knock in the boots i can't not sing
it wow that's that's a good one give me
some good love some body rock and knock
into boots now knocking the boots
uh as it turns out was an old western
slang yeah because from the cowboy days
the boots but
in the 90s you got all of these rappers
wearing timberlands they're wearing
boots
and then they're talking about like you
think it's from where you're wearing the
boots while making love because i always
pictured it was you had the boots off
and they were next to the bed and the
bed is moving the floor and so the floor
the boots are going up and down on the
floor um yeah you think people wearing
shoes making love that's where it boots
that's where i have the answer to that
question okay back in the western era
where it first came about yeah it was
like you're putting your boots under the
bed who's whose bed have your boots been
under okay shout out to shania but um
i owned the bell biv devoe
poison
tape poison poison
1990
but uh another single off of that was
called do me
oh
they played that at our freaking dance
doomy was played at our at our dance
again 12 years old 13 years old
take a look at me tell me do you like
what you see do you think you can do you
think you can do do
me
kiss me pretty baby touch me all over
girl what makes you think you can do me
do you think you can do me girl
do me baby
ho oh
do me baby do you think you can do
me
baby
do me baby
second verse got it do me
girl let your hair down
take off your clothes
and leave on your shoes ah
yes would you mind if i looked at you
for a moment that is kind of sexy before
i make sweet love
then
then the other guy comes in i think this
is uh
i don't know if it's bell biv or devoe
but i mean
yeah i need to throw one of them under
the bus
[Laughter]
backstage underage adolescent how you
doing fine she replied
i like to do the wild thing
action took place
kind of wet
don't forget
the j the i the m the m the y
why
y'all the gym jimmy i need a body bag
you got to work so his only concern was
wearing a condom good gracious what year
was this
1990. so yeah this is troubling right
backstage slightly problematic underage
adolescent
how you doing fine she replied
action took place
this is
this is not good this is uh i mean
this is like the commission of a crime
in a song yeah but this is not the type
of thing
i don't know this was on the radio
yeah it just makes me feel uncomfortable
you know and it's yeah i mean again and
it's not about this is not the only song
that it spoke of such things but you oh
for many many many years this is
probably the very end of
i would say that by the by the end of
the 90s
no one's talking about this in in
popular music
yeah but there was a lot in the 90s was
the ushering out of this being something
that like yeah we could talk about this
and try to make it seem like it's okay
by talking about it you know
so it's just a weird
bad bad choice of a lyric but there was
a lot of like very overt let's
let's sing about sex like i mean you but
but there was some female empowerment
happening back then you got like salt
and pepper with like soup
and then after that was let's talk about
sex you know it was
they were very empowered but they were
in so
definitely a precursor to what we're
seeing today but you and so
they were doing good work
in my opinion but you got people like
color me bad which had to add an extra d
on the end it's like well you're
compensating for something you're
literally adding another d at the end of
bad
and then they open that pottery place
after that yeah
yeah that's that that is the best thing
1991
um
tick tock you don't stop to the tick
tock you don't stop
uh yeah
girl you make me feel real good we can
do it till we both wake up
it's like oh really
in my experience that's
you know we can both do it in our sleep
yeah yeah that's that's potentially
problematic as well depending on your
interpretation of
those events i think it just means let's
do it into the morning and i think uh it
was just it just made a i do think it's
possible though
you can fall asleep in in in in the act
of coitus i mean if you're i think the
active quota stops the point when you're
[ __ ] honestly when you're done but
you like
you stay
yeah in position
yeah well
i mean there's that what's that i'm a
very large man my wife is pretty small i
don't think this is a what are you
talking about i'm saying your entire
body i weigh 210 okay 200 yeah you're
coming up to your whole body i just want
to clarify that
i don't you're the night brother i fell
asleep inside you that like oh merle
haggard talked about that kind of no we
talked about falling asleep on the floor
the night we made love in the hallway
and slept all night long on the floor it
was the merle song
he didn't specify they were still
conjoined that's how i've always
pictured it i'm talking about the third
eye blind song okay
uh anyway to get back to this where's my
tab
um
yeah i want to sex you up
i want to sex you up
all night girl you make me feel good
i want to sex you up like this was just
happening on the radio there was no get
you know it was the point
where that just started happening i
remember the first time i was riding in
the car with my mom and like that george
michael song came on i want your sex and
my mom was just singing it i've told
this story before because it's just it's
it it really
scarred me good question i don't want
you no sex oh i scarred you
but she's the one who gave you the
pamphlet it was pretty good though you
know it was a good message it was like
my mom's just jamming in this in the car
i don't want sex
hey mom i'm also in the car
can you just wait until i'm not in the
car to sing this george michael song
so but then by the early 90s it was like
yeah how can we just be blatant do me i
i want your sex
i want to sex you up but if you listen
in fact uh
recently when when i was back home my
parents were talking about um
their favorite song and boy i wish i
could remember it
uh
but it was [ __ ] robin it was like a
1950s song and they were like you know
we listen to that song and we realized
it's really dirty
and i don't remember what it was
basically it was about yeah it was about
just getting into bed and
making love and they it was a little bit
more coded than the stuff is today but i
think that's the thing is that we have
this perception
i think this is a one of the points that
you're making when you talk about the
the [ __ ] thing
you know
especially from our background of being
sort of culturally conservative for a
really long time
uh you have this tendency to think that
the disposition is to think that things
are devolving uh morally over time right
that's that's how we
used to think right it's like things are
getting worse right people are the
standards are getting lower whereas when
you have a progressive mindset you you
think about it from a different
standpoint which is people are getting
more rights people are getting more
acceptance people are
uh you know
able to express themselves
in ways that they
used to not be able to express
themselves due to oppression or whatever
yeah
um and i think that that's true
but the point i i i i find interesting
is that
they've all everyone's always been
talking about these things everyone's
always been singing about them
everyone's always been writing about
them
and just because the curtains are pulled
back a little bit more and it's a little
bit more honest and explicit and i'm
saying it's the word explicit literally
means like
very very clear and unveiled
uh
and how does that make it worse i think
is the question
yeah you were singing about the same
thing
50 years ago you're still singing about
it
you know there's some things that are
problematic like being able to spot the
actually problematic thing like you
spotted in that devote song it's like oh
now we're talking about somebody being
taken advantage of now we're talking
about a power imbalance now we're
talking about somebody's will and rights
being violated in like an underage
situation like that's the piece of that
that we need to be able to recognize it
isn't the fact that someone's saying do
me
right is the bad thing people have been
saying do me since the dawn of time and
by the way that's how we all got here
because somebody did somebody
you know what i'm saying
um so they could have done it in the
morning they could have done it in the
night they could have done it when they
want to do it
just do me and so even something that to
me seemed very
incongruous back in the day to hear
hammer talk about soft and wetness
softness and wetness and then praying
two songs later
i think the point is is that hammer may
have understood more than we gave him
credit for at the time now
i do not believe his music holds up
but
i i'm not looking back with the same
kind of judgment that i had at the time
you can't touch this was a un unbridled
un undeniable pop hit and it it has to
hold up i do not accept that that
particular song well mostly because it
was like a bass line from another song
that was actually really good yeah yeah
i mean yeah if you're gonna co-op rick
james super freak right then you're
you're off to a good start yeah so all
you gotta do is like that [ __ ]
i'm gonna just keep playing this loop
it's never gonna get old i feel like we
learned a lot i mean there's been the
you know i i love playing music in the
house like
profanity is something that we've
we tried to not just let run around
blatantly in our house as the kids were
younger but like
lando's finally gotten to a point where
he's like all right i've lost this
battle you know it's this is just part
this is this is reality people say these
things he doesn't he's not happy with it
right but he doesn't like
exit the room anymore and he'll ask
nicely if i'm playing something that is
um
too too many curses too much but it but
again to me it's not about the curse
words it's about like the content of
what he's saying is i it's
is he about to get an education at 12
that he's not ready for i'm not gonna
play that no i'm not gonna play that in
the house i'm not gonna play that in the
car i'm not gonna play [ __ ]
in the car with my kid like
somebody expressing themselves with a
few with some colorful language i just
think that's
you know that's self-expression it's
language i think you start with soft and
wet
you know you start with soft and wet
and then you move to [ __ ]
if you're you want my advice
i mean
there's definitely there's definitely
like a profanity playlist that i can put
in there that would be funny like to
create a like by the end of this
playlist you're going to be totally
debauched
like wait that would just be a funny
exercise i think he'll get there on his
own
just i'm the i'm dears i'm the
i'm like the dad who's like trying to
get yourself no no i'm a d i'm the i'm
the sex education dj
like i'm gonna take you down on a
musical journey
like well we were talking about you need
a helmet maybe you just wear a giant
condom over your face
what if you breathing is gonna be an
issue no no it looks like you can't
breathe but that's the i don't want to
be a i don't want to be a
if you were a dj a personified condom
but think about it no this is just this
is just one idea would invite you this
is not all the public schools would
invite you you'd be like the program i'm
not a clown dude they're like the condom
the
dj condom is
dj jimmy
is coming hat
jimmy hat is coming to our school dance
who's that well i think it's that guy
from good mythical morning
uh he's also a dj who wears a condom
over there
okay i'm gonna put jimmy hat on the list
but i'm not gonna be a okay i'm not
gonna be a mascot condo what if you just
wear a hat yeah i'm saying and if you
look closely you see that it's made of
like condom wrappers
if you look closely oh he is wearing a
jimmy hat
just something to think about
because it's a sex education thing
you're the safe sex guy and you're like
fulfilling your mother's life work at
the health department that pamphlet that
she gave you back in the day about
yeah soft heavy and wetness
is now
coming to fruition as you're teaching
all the children about safe sex through
cool music you know i i do have my next
gig
oh yeah i know about it yeah
are you expecting to be paid for that
because it's at my home
are you no hold on you know you're
bringing your top you're set you're
you're top yeah i'm i'm wearing a top
and are you going to be tapping into my
sounds we got to figure that out yes i
mean i don't know i'm not i'm not
renting a sound system that's on you so
well my sound system you can tap into it
through uh just like a uh either
apple or like a google like you can you
can cast to it can dj jimmy hat do that
uh
we need we need to do a test
you need to test this where are you
setting up
you need to start thinking about all
this i i'll i'll consult but that's an
extra fee just i gotta show up just so
you know uh
we're doing like a little graduation
party for a lock that includes it's not
like all his friends
that's a different thing it's oh really
well no it no it's it is i was djing for
your son and his friends no no which
could sound sad but i'm excited no no
it's it's it is his friends but it's
mostly like
the families that
he kind of knows and kind of grew up
around and also he's like his very
closest friend so it's not like hey i'm
inviting everybody from my
school i don't know how i mean i don't
want to do that i'm not involved that's
not that's not what i'm that's not what
i want i thought this was just like
all of his friends this is like a real
party that needs a real deal yeah i need
to talk to my wife she's the party
planner like if there's going to be a
bunch of adults and i'm sitting there
like why is link djing over there why is
he not at the party
that's gonna feel weird but
but can't you get get it going and then
walk away
yes
i feel like but you said that you wanted
to do that that's not d like barbecues
yeah and i assume that you still wanted
to be a part of the action well that's
not dj in the conversation it's not real
i think you may be inventing a new style
of djing
i
i am
i'm a member of the party but i'm also
the dean okay
all right
i'm sure that this is a thing that
exists i can do that but that's not what
i thought i was signing up for you
thought you're gonna like a booth and
you're gonna be like protected from
everyone yeah i don't want to be
touching these teenagers i don't i don't
want them to be like
getting in my space
well we need to talk we need to talk
more about this okay
i wanted to get i wanted to take a cool
party with
it's going to be a cool party
not as some kids
not my friends there might be
more kids than i realize honestly i
don't know we'll talk about it we'll
talk about it later um you have a wreck
it's my wreck you know what i recommend
i recommend us ending this episode with
some of the voicemails that we've gotten
that allude to previous episodes so as
we talked about that's what i'm going to
do i'm going to recommend that you keep
listening
as we shut this out can i say that yeah
i don't necessarily want this to
necessarily
mean
that we can't have a we can't also have
a wreck and voice we deserve the right
to have rex
i am i am i have a wreck
it's continue listening
to the to the closing voicemails
and if if you want to leave one 1888
earpod one
we i listen i love listening to these
messages thank you for calling it's cool
some people are correcting us some
people are
answering questions that we ask some
people are giving perspectives on things
and like these two you're gonna hear
uh some people are just
telling us some
some funny tidbits from their lives
hi uh my name is jackie
uh so i just had to share a funny
coincidence with you guys um so this
morning on my way to work i was
listening to the um episode the your
episode where link was sharing um
lewis's memoir
and just as he got to the part where he
was talking about uh where his reading
section
of lewis living in dc and running up and
down the washington monument
um i on my morning commute was driving
past the washington monument um which
was just such like a cool coincidence
um and that reminded me um
several years ago now there was an
episode um and i can't remember the
details of it but i know that there was
someone called mr noodle
um
and uh i was also driving while
listening to it and uh a minivan pulled
in front of me and the license plate was
noodle which again such a weird
coincidence um so you know that's two
times that uh
your biscuits has uh lined up with
something that i am experiencing
currently in my real world life
which you know is only a few times but
it's two whole times so uh anyway cool
thought i'd share that with you uh
thanks for all the fun stories bye this
is kind of random but
i was listening to i think it was your
most recent air biscuit about many days
for each other
and rat's wreck was to just go to the
doctor if something hurts
and that's really funny because
my wrist has been bothering me all day
and i think it's from the injury i had
in high school which was
maybe like
six or seven years ago at this point so
and i keep thinking in the back of my
head i should probably go to an
orthopedist orthopedist and get this
checked out but i just haven't done it
so maybe i just needed
rhett to tell me to go do it so thank
you rhett
you rock
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]